This video is brought to you by Vessey footwear.
What's up wisecrack Michael,
here to talk about the most contentious issue of 2021. So divisive,
it could destroy the fabric of society or at the very least to wreak havoc on
your local Costco.
You come in close back off.
That's right.
We're talking about masks or that humble six by nine inch piece of fabric that
manages to bring thousands of grownups.
To tears. And they want to throw God's wonderful breathing system out the door.
This potentially life saving piece of cloth that obscures approximately
56.2% of your face is causing drama all over the country.
Especially amongst my fellow,
Florida men and by and large viral videos of these masculine masses have yielded
widespread derision from the Twitterati.
But what if this is the wrong strategy as people fundamentally obsessed with
both not catching the plague and slam dunking on pseudo-science. We,
a wisecrack are left wondering our shame and ridicule the answer.
How can we encourage our fellow Wawa patrons to hide their beautifully shaped
mouth?
Say you left Walla. I did because of the voluntarily,
because I refuse to wear them.
Yes, believe it or not. This is not a new problem.
Public health interventions have been inconveniencing and annoying Americans for
years, whether we're being told to smash safely, stop exhaling,
secondhand smoke, or wear a seatbelt.
So some volunteer firefighter doesn't have to scrape you off the side of the
road, but what public health officials learned from decades of trying to make
Americans behave, let's find out in this widespread condition.
America hates masks now, but before we continue,
I'm want to give a shout out to Vesey footwear for sponsoring this video a
little while ago, they sent over these gray cityscape sneakers.
And as a sneakerhead, I was excited to test them out.
You see Vesey shoes are 100% waterproof.
And while I'm not experiencing that much rain in Southern California,
I thought these could be perfect for when I do end up going home or on long
trips vessels are the perfect everyday sneaker. They are lightweight,
stretchy and made of diamond text material,
which is a dual climate knit material that regulates temperature,
no matter where you are, the best part is when you purchase a very Vesey shoes.
You know, your money is going towards something great.
Since the start of this global pandemic investee has donated over 300,000 masks
to frontline workers and they continue to give back to the community to check
out their page, to see how they're being active. Right now,
you can get your own pair of SES by visiting Vesey, footwear.com/wisecrack.
When you use our link, you'll get a discount. So check it out. Now,
back to the show masks have been warned to STEM the spread of diseases to
varying degrees of success. Since the 17th century,
when the resurgence of the Movantik plague had doctors looking like the stuff of
nightmares, fortunately,
modern doctors prefer the more scientifically grounded and less terrifying
surgical or in 95 masks.
Now for a quick primer on how masks work in regard to COVID.
Every time you open your gross pie hole, you spew invisible,
disgusting droplets of your inner filth. When you're after mentioned,
filth includes tiny COVID-19 particles.
These droplets can make your fellow human sick masks worn correctly.
Block these droplets, preventing others from inhaling your disgusting lung Jews.
And that's probably why most Americans are wearing masks at least once per week,
which okay. Is better than nothing among the complicated and contentious issues.
Our country faces.
This one seems like it should be about as controversial as please wear pants.
And Denny's so why the furious response to being told to cover your face,
hope to understand America's mask phobia.
Let's look back at the last time we were asked to wear masks, not on Halloween,
the 1918 to 1919 influenza outbreak, AKA the Spanish flu.
It was a devastating pandemic, ultimately afflicting around 500 million people.
Then one third of the world's population, it was super fatal,
particularly for healthy 20 to 40 somethings afflicted countries relied on many
of the same public health strategies.
We grumbly follow today like neurotic hand-washing and canceling every fun house
party, except, you know,
they didn't have Netflix or zoom trivia to help their sanity.
And then there were the gauze masks while they'd become a common site in
American hospitals mask wearing by the masses was among the most novel public
health practices introduced during this pandemic.
According to historian Nancy Toms,
as the flu spread public health authorities across the country,
encouraged people to make and wear these masks.
And some cities even passed laws requiring them.
San Francisco issued such a mandate in October,
1918 with detractors being subject to a fine or up to 10 days, imprisonment,
many other cities and States attempted to do the same,
but were stymied by resistance from city council officials or boards of health
as explained by university of Michigan, Jay Alexander Navarro,
and in places where laws were passed,
they sometimes caused quite a stir interestingly Navarro notes that it was mass
ordinances rather than the very strict lockdowns that seemed to have provoked
the most anger from the masses in response,
local governments were met with intense defiance sound familiar.
One is specially interesting parallel between the two pandemics though lies in
who was wearing masks and who wasn't according to a U S national library of
medicine report. Men were the weak links in hygienic discipline in 1918,
a newspaper article from the time paints a picture.
The average man wear the mask slung to the back of his neck until he came inside
of a policeman.
And most people had holes cut into them to stick their cigars and cigarettes
through recent polls have shown similar mask wearing reluctance amongst men
today making the Spanish flu error response to masculine dude bros,
particularly instructive for us.
So how did we deal with these mustachioed cigar chewing rebel babies in
response to male mask phobia,
public health officials adapted a more modern manly form of public health.
Steve didn't discipline patriotism and personal responsibility.
We see this ethos and in 1919 ad,
which features a masked guy urging the public to stamp out the Spanish,
you know, the way manly men do these patriotic efforts,
piggybacked of a massively successful world war one ad campaign,
which invokes the civic duty required of every American,
an ad from the red cross.
Even warned that the man woman or child that will not wear a mask now is a
dangerous slacker.
Similarly American vaccine campaigns over the years have also framed getting
vaccinations as a patriotic duty quite successfully,
particularly when it came to eradicating polio and make no mistake efforts to
convince Americans to Don Macs were largely effective as a story in John and
Barry writes in his book,
the great influenza mask were seen everywhere and will become a symbol of the
epidemic.
A wide network of churches and charities developed to produce masks and millions
of Americans made their own at home.
A gauze covered face became a not particularly sexy symbol of your patriotism.
And I know,
I know getting someone to help other people so that they feel like a man is a
very weird ask, but Hey, if it works, can we get the old spice guy in on this.
Biggest possible when your man smells like old spice and not a lady I'm on a
horse now.
It's important to note that mass squaring in 1919,
wasn't a magic bullet experts have advanced different theories as to why mask
didn't effectively stop the spread of influenza.
Like people made masks and then wore them incorrectly,
or they didn't wash them enough where they'd remove them while socializing.
No and address don't you shoes in store. What else? Project it's your birthday.
It is not my birthday.
That makes sense.
Also influence it travels in much smaller airborne droplets can COVID-19 making
it harder to block for the mask.
But I digress because we're talking about how to get people to wear masks,
to protect against something.
They can actually stop the spread of the novel coronavirus,
despite successful appeals to patriotism and Manliness.
During the influenza pandemic,
there were still plenty of griping and complaining,
particularly in places where masks became legally mandate. Most infamously,
there were the 2000 or so detractors who formed the San Francisco anti mask
leak. But even those who will bade were thoroughly annoyed.
When the mask order was lifted in San Fran, after mere weeks,
everyone collectively cheered and tore their masks off leaving the sidewalks and
Reynolds strewn with the relics of a torturous month.
Clearly Americans have a lot of feelings about the combined indignities of
wearing a mask and being told what to do this led scholar, Laura Spinney,
to suggest in her book about the 1918 pandemic that people have a low tolerance
for mandatory health measures.
And what's more that such measures are most effective when they're voluntary,
when they respect and depend on individual choice.
And when they avoid the use of police powers and other words,
it's sometimes better to inform citizens with the facts about masks, vaccine,
seatbelts, et cetera.
So as to arm them with information so that they do the right thing,
there's probably a lot of you watching this who don't drink and drive because
it's a Dick move that could kill somebody rather than out of a specific fear of
getting arrested.
Recent evidence suggests that mandates can increase compliance for masks wearing
seatbelts and vaccinations.
Even if public health experts typically prefer education over enforcement,
indeed Spinney notes that a 2007 CDC pandemic policy suggested
relying on voluntary compliance with public health measures,
less mortality rates exceed 1%.
The point is there's a limit to how far playing nice will go for the CDC when
confronting death.
It's also important to note that even if we can successfully get most people to
wear masks, it's useless if they do so incorrectly. This was a huge problem.
During the Spanish flu,
tons of people were crappy masks and they wore them wrong.
Besides the after mentioned cigarette holes,
the very idea of which makes my head flowed people used inadequate materials
like cheesecloth, or they exposed their noses or they recycled dirty masks.
We're obviously seeing a similar problem today with mask bales,
plaguing everyone from nose breathers,
to people wearing valve mask that filter air coming in while expelling
disease they're out for everyone else to enjoy. Arguably,
this could be combated with more robust messaging about the correct kinds of
masks to wear and exactly how to wear them.
Particularly given that Americans are accessible by more methods of
communication than ever before.
Like why wasn't this YouTube video annoyingly prefaced with a federally
sponsored public health commercial telling you to cover your mouth and nose.
So we're also protected from the COVID molecules,
camping out in your buggers and why isn't the government making fun Twitter
videos about hand-washing all in all the 1918 pandemic demonstrates that
education should be our first line of defense against pandemics.
The influenza pandemic offers a really simple one-to-one comparison for
examining America's mask phobia. However,
it's also worth examining another more recent public health education effort,
the HIV AIDS epidemic and resulting campaign to increase condoms.
Look at the early years of this crisis and you'll see parallels to our current
predicament. First and foremost,
there was an entirely new virus to educate people about.
In a healthy individual.
There are twice as many T helper cells as T suppressor cells in people with age,
this ratio is reversed.
Secondly,
the federal government basically ignored it and hoped it would go away.
Whereas in the spread, thirdly, people who took it seriously were often mocked
Even by president Reagan's own press secretary who responded to one reporter's
questions about AIDS by intimating,
that the reporter was himself infected with the virus.
Okay.
American government was deadly silent about the virus for years.
There were worldwide public health efforts attempting to promote awareness in
the early eighties, mostly by seriously freaking people out.
Some ads went so far as to use imagery of tombstones and grim reapers.
As researchers from population action, international found such campaigns.
Hadn't provided information about HIV AIDS nor suggested new behaviors effective
in preventing HIV, acquisition or transmission.
And essentially only increased fear.
This approach would be echoed later in the decade by some American government
sponsored ads. And it was probably really not smart.
That's not because fear categorically doesn't work.
I won Michigan state meta analysis of fear-based public health messaging shows
the ads that aggressively appealed to fear actually can be highly successful so
long as they are accompanied by the message that people can take effective steps
to protect themselves. However,
fear based ads like our green Reaper that don't empower people to protect
themselves are counterproductive resulting in defensiveness or denial.
Similar studies have come to the same conclusions about anti-drug ads like the
infant. And this is your brain on drugs, which offers the viewer.
No suggestions on how to take personal action rather than spurring people to
change their behavior. Relying purely on fear seems to make people shut down.
Maybe even giggled don't have sex cause you will get pregnant and die,
but AIDS education, wasn't all death incarnate early on in the epidemic.
activists stepped up to fill the void created by U S governmental and action and
widespread homophobia.
These activists took public health education into their own hands. For example,
one 1983 pamphlet made by activists pioneered the concept of safer sex
teaching specific behaviors that could drastically reduce people's risk of
contracting AIDS without stamping out their sex lives entirely such messaging.
According to public health scholar,
taszlin J padamsee was oriented towards changing individual behavior by
transforming community norms.
Most specifically by turning condom use into a common practice for gay men,
such community-based educational efforts were according to [inaudible]
remarkably effective at stemming the spread of the disease. Accordingly.
These independent efforts establish some best practices in public health that
continue today specifically by encouraging simple,
clear directives targeted towards those who most need to receive the message in
contrast America's government sponsored AIDS campaigns in the mid to late
eighties,
focused on the message that anyone can get AIDS without specifying the critical
fact that certain groups faced a disproportionate risk here,
we see the way public health messaging made by members of the community for
their community can be remarkably effective and can even kickstart wider public
health efforts,
which is probably partially why you maybe receive somewhat comprehensive sex ed
in school. In other words,
teaching people how stuff works is a really good idea.
Some might say it's the basic foundation on which to do this.
This channel was founded and of course it's messy and tricky and tiring.
There are some people who will not be convinced by any amount of evidence that
this Facebook post is not scientific fact.
And there are times when you have to take extreme action, like barring someone,
the joy of picking up Kung Pao cauliflower in order to make them behave
responsibly at least temporarily. But regardless,
we should probably at least try to educate our friends and loved ones to please
for the love of God, cover your disease holes, but in a nice way. Well,
what do you guys think would nationwide messages about masks that stress our
patriotic and moral duties be more effective?
All the Twitter shaming in the world,
or as getting this guy to wear a mask is simply impossible.
Let us know you think in the comments. Huge,
thanks to our dope patrons for supporting the channel and our podcast hit that
subscribe button. And as always, thanks for watching.
Later,
[inaudible].